I am councilor Catherine Grandin
chairman of baber District Council and I
will be chairing this meeting today
my first will remind you of some
domestic Arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs
cold water is available in the breakout
area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on Ipswich Town
Football Club training pick
do not re-enter the building until
you're told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except whether a confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you'll be deemed by the council
to have consented to being filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
before I move on to the agenda
I just want to say that this is the
first opportunity to meet at full
Council
since the sad death of our Queen
so I just wanted to say a few words to
pay tribute to our late Queen
like most people
haven't got any reminiscences of meeting
the queen personally
I can't Regale you with anecdotes of
being in her company
I saw her at various creeping of the
color parades and balcony ways for oddly
one of the occasions I remember most was
when I accompanied my children's school
to a park in Ipswich in 2002 for a
fleeting glimpse of the queen and the
Duke of Edinburgh as they drove past
but like most people I feel like he
touched and influenced my life
even though my actual connections were
limited
the first time we learned about our
Queen's passing will provide one of
those momentous moments in our lives
where we will always remember where we
were what we were doing and recall our
initial shock
for most or many of us Queen Elizabeth
is the only monarch we have known
we have grown up singing God Save the
Queen all our life from school days
onwards
collecting our service to her as Scouts
and guides and in the forces and many
other ways
our history education is bound by
learning about our monarchs we study the
dates they reigned the wars undertaken
their relationships with their concert
consorts
the clothes they wore and their
relationships with their subjects and
ministers
the queen that lived alongside our lives
did all that and more
Queen Elizabeth II led by example
we have heard much recently about how
the queen demonstrated what true service
means
her dedication as we know included
asking the prime minister to form a
government just two days before she died
I won't list examples of the Queen's
dedication to service to her country as
we all have our favorites
but her example of putting Duty and
Service First
serves to provide us counselors with a
template of how to live our life when in
office
the queen offered to dedicate her whole
life to her country when she was 21.
and we can try to emulate her by
dedicating just four years of our life
to our district
we have a chance to reflect why we
decided to stand for election in the
first place
perhaps recalibrate in consider how we
can try to follow our Monarch's example
of what true and selfish service is
in our own smaller way
I didn't bring them on my marmalade
sandwich
but I will say
thank you ma'am
for everything
and God Save the King
I will now move to the agenda
item one
apologies for absence
thank you chair I have received
apologies for absence from counselors
Fraser Mel Daisy Gould Huron and cancer
carpondale
thank you
item two Declaration of Interest by
councilors
are there any Declarations of Interest
thank you
item three paper BC
2217 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on 21st June 2022 for
accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
thank you may I have a proposal please
councilor Busby
may I have a secondary please councilor
Davis
thank you I will now ask the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct the vote it'll be a raised hand
vote please
thank you chair all those in favor
that is Karen today
thank you
that's carried
um item four
paper VC 22 18 announcements from the
chairman and leader
I refer you to paper
bc2218 for noting thank you and I just
thought I'd mentioned
um we've had some
um talk about the queen and
um I just wanted to make sure I went to
a beautiful service which I know a few
members attended at Barry Saint Evans in
in memory of our Queen and um I think
we're all quite moved of those that us
attended it was a very special service
so uh feels quite a momentous occasion
having today's meeting really
so I will now move on to the next part
of the meeting
councilor Simon Barrett
following a recent code of conduct
complaint outcome from the monitoring
officer requesting that you apologize to
full Council
would you like to take the opportunity
to do so
all right thank you thank you very much
Evan for the opportunity to actually
apologize to council for a slight lapse
in my normal impeccable Behavior I
certainly do apologize to the council
but I would also like to just read the
reason behind my slide lab
was the rather rather poor behavior of
the leader and the deputy leader
laughing at a member of the public who
actually is here today so I hope that
they hope that they actually do um amend
their ways and don't laugh at the
members of the public when they're
speaking uh who then stop me from losing
my I would like to intervene here and
um the video didn't show that but we'll
move on now to the rest of the meeting
um
so what was not shown
sorry what was not shown
I don't believe the that was the reason
but we'll now move on to the video the
Madam chair
so I've admitted
of my own verosity the video did not
conclude anything
so if you can actually direct me in any
other way that would be fine but I can
assure you the video did not show
anything
I have said I latched and I'm very much
in apology okay thank you Council so
there was a reason why that was and it
was the inappropriate behavior of the
leader and the deputy leader at that
particular moment thank you councilor
thank you
I'd like to invite Council War to make
his announcements
thank you chairman Kevin I'm trying to
border the councilor beside me put our
hand up to get your attention
we are not having
daughter thank you madam chairman
firstly uh the deputy leader and I deny
the accusation
um anyway just going on
um my announcements most of this was
written actually for the meeting the
postponed meeting back in July but it is
rather relevant so it's a long time now
and a lot has happened since but at the
end of June we were finally able to have
an LGA conference in person this year
rather than the less than ideal virtual
conferences of the past two years
it was particularly gratifying as this
year the LGA is celebrating 25 years of
supporting local government
the venue was the excellent Harrogate
Conference Center and the end the agenda
was full of interesting and useful
sessions
the only drawback was that it was I
suppose inevitably a super spreader
event and many of us from Suffolk
returned with covert
I just want to highlight a small part of
the conference but there was much more
that I could relate this evening
the conference began with an address
from the LGA chairman who spoke about
the impact that local government has had
over the last two years
responding to covert to rapidly
providing support to the newest and most
vulnerable members of our society who
have arrived from Ukraine
his speech focused on the immediate cost
pressures facing councils and the issue
of abuse faced by councilors and echoed
new newly re-elected LGA president
baroness gray Thompson saying that we
cannot allow this Behavior to be
normalized I will return to this topic
in a few minutes
he also called for local government to
start a conversation about a long-term
Vision which addresses the challenges
that our communities will be facing in
the next five to ten years
in his keynote speech leveling up
secretary Michael Gove outlined the
principles underpinning the government's
leveling up and regeneration Bill to
deliver an irreversible commitment
towards strengthening local leadership
he committed to Greater Devolution by
offering every part of England a new
Devolution deal by 2030. he also
highlighted the need to improve the use
of data to improve Service delivery he
expressed his desire to strengthen
Innovation and the use of data by
introducing new office for local
government which would includes shine a
light on performance and delivery
and that's that from next year
government would introduce a two-year
Financial settlement to provide councils
with certainty and confidence in
planning budgets while it's also
promising to keep the financial
situation facing councils under review
he also said he was looking closely at
what the department could do to reduce
the number of funding streams and
associated with burdens on councils
however as we all know events can happen
have happened and they do have a habit
of derailing plans
we don't yet know the new secretary of
state's views since the summer we're on
the second new one now but I hope that
Suffolk will still be able to negotiate
a county deal
there were many other sessions
addressing topical themes such as
leveling up cost pressures on local
government finances the future of high
streets sustainable homes the visitor
economy achieving Net Zero cyber
security adult social care reform
support for care leaders improving send
and resilient communities and staff and
Community well-being and there were
plenary sessions from the dehings Nadeem
Sahari Lisa nandi at Davey and baroness
Young
according to new research seven in ten
councilors reported experiencing abuse
and intimidation over the last 10 12
months as a result of this statistic the
LGA launched its debate not hate
campaign at the conference
this will work to challenge the toxicity
of public debate and push for change
and Jackie Weaver were on the panel of
the plenary session that shared ideas or
what can be done to tackle this
hopefully we will be hearing a lot more
of this campaign and it can be followed
by a hashtag debate not hate
in July the chairman and I attended the
annual Suffolk Chamber of Commerce
Garden Party held on the rooftop garden
of the Willis building this was the
first time it was held since 2019 and it
was bigger and better than ever
and last month along with the deputy
leader I attended the annual Chamber of
Commerce Prestige dinner at Western park
again it was great that this event is
back on the calendar
the Suffolk chamber is a vibrant
organization and achieves a lot for the
county
it was really good to talk to many
people and hear how Suffolk businesses
are recovering and looking forward to
the future
thank you chairman
thank you Council award
item five
to save notification of petitions in
accordance with Council procedure rules
thank you chair none received
item six
questions by the public in accordance
with Council procedure rules
I refer you to the questions in the
papers
I would like to invite Mr Riley to ask
his question
Mr Riley
thank you madam chairman uh before I ask
my question I'd like to actually
congratulate councilor Ward
on the very skillful way he evaded
directly answering my supplementary
question last time
out here and um
it reminded me that I had actually seen
such skillful articulate evasiveness
since councilman can I just ask you to
um stick to the question that you have
supplied yeah are you quite romance I
read 10 advantage to um
praise councilor board the question
Council award is that at the last
meeting you affirmed your belief that
the Redevelopment of corksling would
break even or make a profit
the draft minutes of the council's last
meeting
record you're saying that Bieber has
never said that the project might make a
slight loss
yet report
number BC eight stroke 22 stroke four
suggests that the range of outcomes
would include losses
please tell us why you have ignored the
loss making potential of this project
when your own officers were flagging up
that possibility Oh and before you
answer there will probably be a
supplementary question uh thank you
councilman
thank you councilor Riley uh Mr Riley uh
I'd like to invite Council Ward to
respond thank you
all righty I am surprised that this is
still a matter for debate as you will
have seen from the cabinet decision in
June six options were considered and
based on the evidence provided the one
chosen was the one that provided the
best balance between risk and return for
the council the decision has been made
and work has now commenced
I have to disagree with your assertion
that would report BCA 22 4 suggests the
range of outcomes including a loss for
our chosen option and that we have
ignored this
I think you must have misread it the
report clearly states the following in
section 2.2
now quote on this basis phase one of
phase 2A currently show a break-even
development with the potential for a
small profit Circa 50 to 100 000 pounds
further profit could subsequently be
available from phase 2B
now I know you claimed at Junior's
council meeting that we or I have said
that the development would break even or
make a slight loss this is surprising
for I have a no repeat never said any
such thing
and I hope you don't mind my reminding
you you acknowledge that I did in fact
say the opposite that it would make a
small profit in your own blog written
three weeks prior to that meeting
ultimately the profitability of any
development is reliant on sale prices
and the market at the time of sales
occurring having said that the most
important thing is that this scheme will
deliver positive outcomes for Hadley and
The Wider District
by providing high quality housing and
investing in our district
foreign
would you like to ask a supplementary
question
please note that the supplementary
question must be related to the original
question and should not be proceeded
with a statement
uh thank you madam chairman
well
bearing in mind the way this has gone
kick it backwards and forwards I believe
this supplementary question does have a
distinct relationship
to what we've been discussing
as this Council award
bearing in mind comments made by your
colleagues the feature an emotion to be
debated later this evening
do you consider yourself to be a Tory
out of bastard a reformed actor bastard
Mr Riley this is not an appropriate
question
could you ask an appropriate and
I'll have to ask you to sit down if
you're if you continue like this please
Madam chairman it would not be the first
time I've disagreed with the Chairman's
decision
and embarrassing your wishes I will sit
down but the question remains what sort
of accent bastard are you
[Applause]
right I would now like to invite Mr
Ferguson to ask a question
thank you very much indeed Madam
chairman can I first of all say I am
delighted that we have at least started
work on corks Lane after this period of
time
um my question Madam chairman is for the
cabinet member for finance assets and
Investments
I understand the gipping construction
has been selected as Bieber's builder
for the Redevelopment of corks Lane
and the gipping is a local company
excellent
can the cabinet member for finance
assets and Investments tell me if
gipping were chosen through a
competitive tender process
and if so how many other companies bid
for the work
has a contract to gipping been awarded
on a firm fixed price basis
and what is awarded to the lowest
compliant bidder
finally to fully understand the risks
that they were potentially faces with
completing this development on time and
on cost
will you provide a copy of the tender
documents that were provided to bidders
that's not the responses because I
understand there will be commercial and
confidence
but to give me an indicative percentage
of the differences in bid price between
gipping and any other compliant bidders
Mr Ferguson I'd like to invite councilor
Busby to respond thank you
um
question one yes skipping were chosen
through a competitive tender process
carried out by baber growth limited who
are delivering this project on behalf of
the council
question two the contractor gipping has
been awarded on a fixed price basis
based on the specification and employers
requirements question three yes the
contract was awarded to the lowest
compliant bidder
question four the tender documents have
now been superseded by the contact that
baber growth limited has with gipping so
the tender documents are not relevant in
assessing risks with completing the
development on time and on cost this
will be controlled through management of
the contract that has a completion date
of April 24 as well as robust program
and risk management by the professional
team as we all know projects can and
will be affected by outside influences
such as inflation Global Supply Chain
issues and other world events however
claims are limited to those recognized
through the contract
final question the percentage difference
between the top bidder and the bottom
bidder was about 14 percent
thank you Council
Bassin would you like to ask a
supplementary question I would please
Madam chairman thank you and could I
just say thank you to the council for
that comprehensive response to my first
question
my supplementary question of council
Busby um our promises a very brief
explanation why I need to ask it if you
look at the gipping construction zone
website there are three things that I
picked up uh in particular
one is about 65 of the contracts that
have been awarded to them
offer less than one million pounds so
quite small there
and by my calculation the average value
of all of the listed contracts and there
are about 79 of them if you take the
total value and divided by 79 it comes
to just less than a million pounds
um
and so my concern really is that we're
looking at relatively small numbers and
giving appears to have very limited
experience of working on lifted listed
buildings
so my question then is against that
company background as corks Lane is a
high value project with a slender if any
margin
um did baber carry out a risk assessment
of gippings construction gipping
construction's ability to deliver corks
Lane contract on time and on cost
and if so can I have sight of that risk
assessment in place
yes we did carry out a risk management
assessment uh no sorry you can't have a
view of that
gipping a local company which is one of
the things that you were pleased to hear
about we have looked at the work they
have done for the council and for others
and we're happy with that quality of
work
they provided a good tender
the lowest price
and we feel that we can work well with
them it's a vapor growth driven project
and labor growth will ensure that we get
delivered on time as for this
profit that I have keep hearing about
the first phase is marginal the first
phase is marginal which is the
conversion of the original building the
overall project will deliver a profit
okay the overall phase will deliver a
project
so it will deliver profit so
can I is that the last time we hear
whether it's marginal or not because
it's not marginal
move on now
afraid there is no more supplement
questions
um we'll move on now to item seven
questions by counselors in accordance
with Council procedure rules
I refused the question in the papers I
would like to invite councilor beer to
ask his question
thank you madam chairman so I was trying
to get it up on here I've managed to get
there I'm getting better at all this
um
my questions to the leader of the
council could you please advise me and
the taxpayers of favor if the Surplus
one million four hundred thousand pounds
that you have found can be allocated to
offset any council tax increase that you
may be thinking of introducing in the
fofcommon 2023
2024 budget as our residents
are already struggling with the High
Cost of Living
energy and fuel price increases amongst
other fins we don't want to be seen as
Empire Building or just increase in our
Reserves
thank you
thank you I would like to invite Council
thank you for your question
you say I'm not really sure what that's
a reference to but anyway we've started
consider the 2023-24 budget but it's far
too early for me to make any comment
about its contents as you will see from
the 2021-22 outturn report approved by
cabinet in July we have made several
transfers to Reserves including setting
up a new 500 000 pound inflationary
pressures Reserve
this will be used to mitigate the impact
of inflation on our finances where this
cannot be achieved through funding or
other income this is a one-off solution
to help mitigate the pressure in the
current year
the council is facing its own energy
fuel prices and inflation new pressures
and in The Current financial year are
likely to overspend by about eight
hundred thousand pounds
these Financial pressures will continue
into 2023-24 and Beyond and are likely
to increase with diminishing reserves to
cover this
this will need to be considered in The
Wider context of the cost of delivering
essential services and the funding we
have available will be a major factor in
any budget considerations this autumn
we are acutely aware of the impact of
the cost of living crisis on our
residents and in June cabinet approved
our cost of living action plan
this is a suite of personalized
preventative measures which focus on
reaching those who are most in need
please don't just focus on cost of
living issues in isolation but also on
our residents well-being
we will be appointing a cost of living
coordinator for 15 months funded by a
government grant and we are among the
first districts in the country to do
this
we have provided Sudbury citizens advice
with a 30 uplift in funding this year so
that they can respond effectively to
increasing demand
we are able to make discretionary
housing payments funded by a government
grant of 85 000 pounds to assist those
on benefits who are struggling with rent
shortfalls
there's a 5.1 million pound household
support Grant across the Suffolk system
to help households with the cost of
Essentials such as food clothing and
utilities
Suffolk public sector leaders has
approved an additional 1 million pound
hardship cost support to the cloud
collaborative communities board for the
system-wide response in Suffolk
and finally
you will know that we have the local
council tax deduction scheme which gives
100 reduction for low-income pension age
residents and currently up to 95
reduction in council tax for low-income
working age residents
following the cabinet decision on Monday
this week this has now been increased to
a hundred percent reduction helping
nearly two and a half thousand residents
so we're doing a huge amount to help
those at most in need
in respect of council tax we always
ensure that our annual increases are
very modest this year was 3.48 per annum
or less than seven Pence a week less
than a penny a day
baber's proportion of the overall cost
attacks excluding Parish precepts is
only 9.5 percent
thank you chairman
thank you Council ward council of beer
would like to ask a supplementary
question again the question must relate
to the original question thank you thank
you statement whatever increasing
council tax whether it's pennies Pence
is still difficult for some people
uh well Lots in fact uh
could I ask then can you
um
confirm that you will not spend any of
this circles one million four hundred
thousand pounds to shore up private
Enterprises such as the doctor's surgery
which I've which is rumored to be
struggling to find financial support
Council award would you like to respond
um
I I explained that the uh the Surplus is
going into reserves and has been put
into reserves
um that the matter of the uh the new
medical center in Sudbury is is a
completely different uh thing altogether
um I can't comment on on the the
progress or otherwise of that particular
project
[Music]
thank you
we'll move on now to item eight BC 22 19
Community infrastructure Levy
expenditure framework fourth review
I would like to invite councilor arthi
to introduce paper BC 2219 and to move
the recommendations in the report
councilor arthi
thank you chair
yes this is um been a little while
coming to you originally scheduled for
the July meeting
so apologies if some of you have already
um
taken all of this in
the so expenditure framework and the
community communication strategy were
originally agreed and adopted by both
councils in 2018.
there have been annual reviews by The
Joint member panel which have led to
changes being adopted to the still
expenditure framework and the community
communication strategy in March 2019
April 2020 and March 2021
it was also agreed that a further review
would take place this year
the report in front of you today is the
result of that work which was undertaken
by the cross Council cross-party joint
member panel
my thanks to councilors beer Jameson and
Clarin
who were babies Representatives on that
panel
the proposed changes are listed in full
at paragraph 4.5 in your report but I
will highlight the main points
firstly changes regarding eligibility
for infrastructure which reduces the
carbon footprint that includes district
and Parish heating systems for communal
buildings within those parishes
currently EV charging points are
supported for 100 of project costs
however we are now suggesting that it
should be up to up to 100 percent
accepting that other funding may be
available and carbon reduction heating
systems should be eligible for district
cell funding where there are
improvements or upgrades or
additionality in community buildings but
that's not repair or maintenance
we have increased Clarity around seal
bids from organizations that charge
admittance
so we will continue to fund
infrastructure for museums but we will
not fund public open spaces and Play
Projects if an admittance fee is charged
we believe that such facilities should
be capable of being used by all without
charge
there are changes to the project inquiry
forms which Aid project development
amongst the improvements to the website
and this is quite an exciting proposal
we want to include maps of both
districts showing locations of completed
seal projects along with details of
those projects and before and after
pictures
we're proposing consistent arrangements
for the use of ring fenced monies using
suggested catchment areas for proposed
infrastructure for schools Rail and
health hubs
where infrastructure delivery is
proposed through the submission of
sillbids the financing of these bids
when recommended to cabinets or through
delegated decisions will be undertaken
by using ring fenced monies first
supplemented by use of strategic or
local infrastructure funds secondly and
if necessary
we have reviewed the current 75 000
pounds threshold you'll remember that
Community bids have a 75 000 pound and
75 threshold
so that total costs for sale bids we are
proposing should increase to 100 000
pounds but still 75 of the total costs
this addresses Rising infrastructure and
material costs
we're proposing changes to the funding
for cycling and footpaths these projects
identified in the LC whip the IDP and
the ifs and if you've forgotten what
they are that's the local cycling and
walking infrastructure plan the
infrastructure delivery plan
a funding statement
we're suggesting a pilot period for
schemes with the new community threshold
of one hundred thousand pounds and
proactive work to bring LC whip schemes
forward with the outcomes informing the
next review
we want to encourage greater spending of
seal including neighborhood seal and we
want to continue with the current
proactive approaches towards expenditure
and progression of sill bids
in addition produce Capital Project work
plans for the next five years with other
infrastructure providers such as health
and Suffolk County Council waste to
address infrastructure priorities
we will monitor alongside the
infrastructure funding statement where
neighborhood sales spend is occurring
and if necessary carry out focused
discussion with the parish about Capital
seal projects that are underway
we will offer targeted website advice
with specific guidance note to Aid
project development and the development
of Pips those are the parish investment
infrastructure plans
and we will look at the use of
neighborhood sale on a case-by-case
basis and monitor this for the next
review of the sill expenditure framework
finally agreement to keep sell
expenditure framework under review I've
mentioned how some of our proposals will
feed into the next review and we are
suggesting another sill expenditure
framework review which will be the fifth
and that should occur whilst bid round
10 is underway so that any revisions are
adopted before bid round 11 in May 2023
now to the sill expenditure framework
communication strategy which is a
appendix B we will continue with regular
briefing sessions for members and Parish
councils in line with the requirements
of the communication strategy but our
proposal is to increase the number of
events from two to three each year with
members also being invited to the parish
events so that they can accompany their
parishes if they wish
I'll refer you to paragraph 4.6 in the
report
lastly that the joint member panel
remains to inform the fifth cell
expenditure framework review
chair I'm proposing the recommendations
of paragraph three that is 3.1 that
baber Council approve the amendments to
the silk expenditure framework July 2020
22 as arising from the fourth review
also appendix a and the cell expenditure
framework communication strategy July
2002
secondly 3.2 that labor Council agree
that the still expenditure framework and
the silk expenditure framework
communication strategy be reviewed again
whilst bidran 10 is being considered so
that any amended scheme can be in place
before bid round 11 occurs in May 2023
finally 3.3 the baber council agree that
the joint member panel be retained to
inform the fifth review
chair thank you
thank you councilor RC could I have a
secondary please
councilor Parker thank you
we'll now move on to questions
counselors may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject under discussion and must
be a question
who would like to start councilor
Barrett councilor Simon Barrack thank
you councilorati for your introduction
um it's glad that the sill is under
review we've had a number of cases where
the restrictions that we've imposed
hasn't really delivered still as it
could be to the communities and I think
the fact that it's under review and we
can keep an eye on that is good we have
a number of projects
um
had been stored which has seen to be now
with the revisions probably being able
to go ahead which is good for their
communities so I think it's very
important that we keep an open mind and
as we the fund of seal keeps the
building that we are able to spend it
appropriately for our communities which
is what it's there for so uh thank you
very much for the report and uh
obviously look forward to supporting you
thank you did you
was
okay
that's nice
councilor Mabry
um thank you very much Madam chairman
um I've got several
and um can I first of all say
I have a fan base at home so good
evening my fan base
um the
one or two things that I would like to
particularly ask
um first of all
um councilor Arthur mentioned that if
museums charge they can apply for sale
money my first question is does that
also apply to galleries which often are
attached to museums or maybe museums in
their own right because they are artists
galleries that's my first question thank
you
and a good question too
um
we haven't specifically looked at
galleries
um my feeling is yes the same should
apply as should apply to museums I'm
looking over towards Christine Thurlow
who obviously helps us
um with the preparation of the framework
reviews and I'm going to suggest that
this is perhaps something that we ought
to pick up is
framework review just to clarify the
situation with regard to galleries I
don't know though if Christian wants to
my view is that they would qualify the
same I don't know if she has the same
view
any Clarity on that that's something
that we can look at in the next review
which will be taking place shortly
thank you very much thank you I'm so
glad I'm abused at times
um thank you very much the there are a
couple of other issues that I have with
this funding for cycling and footpaths
to my mind having tried for so many
years
to get a public footway beside the road
that travels from my home Village into
great wolding field
then at that point I think the costs at
10 years ago was a quarter of a million
I cannot see how a hundred thousand
threshold will actually help with some
of these cycling and footpaths so my
question is
because you've already spoken councilor
Artie about a review in a few months
time perhaps that could be reviewed that
limit on those because we are all
looking at keeping everyone fit and
healthy and this evening as I was
traveling in from Lebanon I had the
vision of some
school girl and it was a female walking
along a very unsafe Road out of lavinum
to a few houses which are situated just
outside of the village and I do actually
think that we need a larger pot for this
type of safety for our citizens and also
to keep our residents fit and healthy so
that's my next question
okay yeah well you'll see that the
proposal I did say to you earlier on the
proposal is a little bit old because we
actually came up with it in the spring
but if you look at what the proposal
says it's asking you
um as Council I'm asking you as Council
to approve the suggestion that we
undertake proactive work for bringing LC
whip schemes forward okay so I don't
know if the scheme that you tried to
pursue some years ago was or is an LC
whip scheme it goes on to say um
position on the pilot skiing stroke
period to be reviewed at the next
that's the fifth silk expenditure
framework review to measure progress
methodology and outcomes for
deliverability of the schemes so I'm
going to bring Christine Thurlow in
again and just ask her if she has an
up-to-date position for people who are
seeking to progress LC whip schemes
thank you there are a number of schemes
that we're looking at at the moment
which are in our our LC whips in respect
of both councils
and we're looking at what we need to do
in order to develop those schemes and of
course how we fund those schemes because
there are limitations uh regarding the
the sill budget and there will be a lot
of competition for what monies are spent
on what projects so as you'll see from
your papers this is a pilot scheme we've
only just gotten to the point where our
LC whips are up and running and we are
developing some projects and taking them
forward and we intend to look at this
again in the next review of the cell
expenditure framework and we're hoping
that we will be able to use the sill
money to get in match funding in order
to bring forward schemes
councilor Mabry
oh I left sorry I left my mic on there I
beg your pardon thank you um Madam
chairman um thank you to councilor Artie
and to um Christine I'm taking that as a
positive that we will see some new foot
ways uh some footpaths and cycling paths
and that a hundred thousand I am taking
from your comments that that possibly is
not enough to cover some of them and I
look forward to this coming forward and
I hope my green colleagues will actually
support me in this because we do
actually need to divert some some monies
towards this they're all looking at
their computers so they're not going to
that's fair enough
um my very last question at the moment
is
um is about the rising costs of building
works now if anyone has tried to build
anything very recently you will find
that the quotations alter not just in a
few weeks time but day by day
and my and my personal experience from
today is that someone had to go to four
different building suppliers
to buy some equipment for my property
please don't check anybody it's only a
bit of guttering
um
what I'm trying to say to you is that I
think this written as it is
that the current six months held period
for quotes should be reduced to four
months and updated I actually think that
that should be reduced even more because
that is too far in advance and if
anybody would like to know I actually
had to pay 44 pounds 85 P for a piece of
guttering and the associated fixings now
I'm going to suggest that sometime ago
that would probably have been about half
that price so from personal experience
I'm saying to all counselors be aware
costs are changing you need to be aware
of these things and for my mind that
part should be changed thank you
Council Rossi did you want to reply yeah
um so if you actually have a look at
what is said under that bullet point and
um
29 yep and it's the penultimate bullet
point
the suggestion is that the current
six-month held period for quotes for
infrastructure led by the community so
these are the community bids
be reduced to four months and so it's
not just that it's and updated quotes
are sought if necessary before decisions
on silk bids okay
so the Seal team have been incredibly
flexible and continue to be incredibly
flexible one of the important things
though is that with their encouragement
the people that are bidding for sale are
actually ready to go at the time that
they're awarded their their sill funding
because the last thing that we want is
to actually approve something on a bid
on a day okay and then the project
doesn't get underway for six months
because that's when the problems are
going to occur So Christine and her team
are being incredibly flexible in
allowing people to revise their bid as
late as she possibly can in terms of the
times so that as soon as they get
approval hopefully they can go the whole
idea of these infrastructure bids is
that they should be ready to go oven
ready they should be ready to go as soon
as we give the approval
the last one I think councilor Mabry yes
this will be the last one but thank you
councilor arthi I understand what you're
saying and we've had experience in our
Ward have we not have these things
happening happening when the sill bid is
is ready but the actual costs have gone
up so I again say that we need to look
at
quotes can be revised
between
the parish actually putting forward
their still bed it being accepted to
make sure that we don't have this state
where the um the parish suddenly finds
that the money that the cost of these
items has gone up as I said it's a day
by day at the moment process increases
all the time
and as I have said through my experience
it's the fact that there are not
and then when they come in again from
wherever that may be either this country
or abroad they have gone up
significantly
for you now
thought off thank you
just to reassure counselor Mabry we will
pick this up again in the next review to
make sure that what we've been doing has
worked if there have been problems look
at whether there needs to be further
revisions
thank you
councilor Lindsay
thank you chair
um and thanks Clive for your councilor
Arthur for your presentation and all the
councilors that were involved in drawing
this up
I guess my question is I've got I'll ask
my question and then I'll explain why
I'm what I'm getting at why I'm asking
it
um
there's a particular there's an item on
Parish heating systems
and uh yeah you may be aware of the case
because I have have talked about it
um
but I just
I suppose my question is can we have I
fully understand the reasons for
um you know just sticking to in
structure
if the infrastructure is ready to go
then you can fund a bit of it
[Music]
but when you have a project that's seen
by government as groundbreaking
as seen as as
unique and and a pilot project
is a sun room for flexibility in there
to give to give grants when we're
talking about feasibility
rather than
Spades in the ground and so the specific
for people who don't know what I'm
talking about the specific one I have in
mind is in my ward where
um in bilderston where they've already
done the first feasibility study into it
into a
building some wide heating system
powered through boreholes
um
uh essentially
um
ground ground Source Heating and piped
to homes
um
the government has has said this is the
most advanced project they're aware of
in in the south of its kind in in the
South
um they've done that first feasibility
they need to do a test borehole
they've got a promise that will cost and
a few other technical checks
so a sort of second feasibility
um
they have been promised 100K 100
000 to cover that to cover
three quarters of that by the government
they need the extra 50k to allow them to
do that
um to do that second feasibility
and that's the specific thing I'm
thinking of but I guess my question is
is I don't want to honestly I can't tie
you down to answering my
just in general is there room for
flexibility on the on the rule about
only only funding Spade ready projects
thanks
yeah it's difficult to answer that
um you'll see in the papers that what we
um considered as a panel was what sill
ought to be available for and we came to
the conclusion that it should be
available for such schemes where
um public buildings are affected because
of the public benefit and its
infrastructure
there was a slightly
um more difficult conversation around a
scheme that simply benefited some
households
so if heating scheme was being put
together and I understand a lot of work
has been done
already
where the aim of the project is simply
to provide people with Greener energy or
cheaper energy bills that that is not a
role for
structure maybe funding
so
um I don't think we've actually got any
um projects that are very far developed
you're absolutely right
um that the one in build
um doing they're doing their eligibility
study there is a similar type a larger
District heating type proposal that
Taylor wimpy
um Council Margaret Maven knows a lot
about this one Taylor wimpy are
proposing on the Chilton Woods
development that of course is a private
initiative if you like
so what we had to consider was
um and we will continue I hate to keep
saying it will be under
but these reviews happen all the time
and every time that we do it we Tinker
with
um every time that we do it we we
introduce things that are a kind of a
Suck It And See type proposal where we
say we'll do something
degree to us doing that and then during
the next review we actually look at how
that sort of pilot Arrangement has
worked how many students have come
forward what sort of money they like
proposals we say that we will do it
Christine and her team can then go out
and look at schemes that we might be
able to fund and then we'll see how much
how much required so we've captured
Margaret major earlier on was quite
right in some of these LC whip schemes
may be far too large to be helped well I
suppose it'd be helped but far too large
Swan by a hundred thousand pounds but
some of them might and some of the
community-led ones may not even cost
that much some of the safer walking to
schools some safer routes so going back
to the district heating I don't think
anything is is particularly well
advanced yet but what we said was
elements of that scheme have related to
public buildings so in other words if
some of the houses were being able to to
receive
piped piped off water if some of the
houses were able to receive it and the
Village Hall was able to receive it or
other public buildings that there would
be a conversation to be had and the
funding might be available and that's
what we're suggesting here that that
opportunity we should explore
thank you thank you councilor RC
councilman craw
l no the question was answered by
somebody else thank you okay thank you
uh councilor Ayers
thank you Chad
um mine's a query about the timing of
the um applications unfortunately
um at the Christmas Center in Sudbury
um they did which is in my ward they
applied for um some cell funding to set
up a very important medical
system for a woman who are suffering
from the menopause which I know one's
not allowed to say but it is topical and
they um
however they put that the um the bid in
in time but then it didn't get there or
whoever should have got it didn't get it
and they were told they've got to wait
for the next bit which is sad because
they had got the bid in and it's the
Christmas Center
and they'd asked for it and um but they
were told they didn't pick it up so
maybe that could be looked at if there
is some sort of to have to wait six
months so hopefully we're just going to
get to get it going because it is vital
but it could be that time lapse thank
you I'll throw Aussie Gemma can I ask
that councilor Ayers and Christine
Thurlow the head of facility
um that they deal with this Arab meeting
perhaps because it's a specific case
um and I think that's probably the best
way to
the best thing to do to deal with that
outside the meeting thank you
councilor Holt
yeah thank you um
just touching on councilman mabry's
earlier comments
with the current climate and the
necessity really to gain fixed
points
um
can you assure me
that we're equipped to make quick
decisions
similar to our own decisions that we
made on corks Lane where we had a fixed
price contract that had to be decided
within a very short time frame
so that would be my question are we
equipped to deal with fixed price
quotations similar to how we did Grow
garden Courtland
I I think the answer is yes I'm I think
the question is more about the speed
um and I think there are two answers to
that one is the sub 10 000 which is done
on delegated decisions and they only go
to go to for noting and Christine deals
with those
within the team the ones that have to go
to cabinet that I present to Cabinet
they do take a bit longer I'm afraid
because Christine has to prepare all of
the papers and the papers all have to go
to Cabinet um before the final approval
is given so there is I'm afraid a little
bit of lag in the over ten thousand
pound schemes just simply because of the
administrative work of getting to
committee the smaller sub 10 000 ones
are quicker
councilor Mayberry
thank you very much Madam chairman
um
my question I can't actually
seeing this paperwork but hopefully
somebody will point me in the right
direction if I've read over it
um if you look at page 37 it's got
assurances the title is assurances for
collection of cell Monies
now we have had a little bit of
difficulty
um to remind councilors over the
collection of Sil mummies from
developers sadly two are in councilor
Artie and my ward
um two different parishes I hasten to
add
I am surprised that we haven't actually
mentioned this in the paperwork about
any specific tightening
of our collections that we are doing so
that's my first question
um and my second is
could someone actually confirm that we
now a debt controller for this type of
work particularly for sill collection
monies thank you
Council arthi
yes we do
um we've now got Debbie osak who is our
silk debt recovery officer and you will
remember that she was successful a few
days before court
in recovering the outstanding debt in
Bears Lane in Lebanon you're absolutely
right there is another one
um
our ward in cockfield an outstanding
debt at the moment and there are others
across the district and in mid-suffolk
some of them are very small
um some of them
um certainly the ones that you're
talking about are quite large
it's important that we as a council do
not rest without recovering those
amounts and Debbie is perfectly clear so
is Christine and her team so is Tom and
I think probably Arthur is as well
absolutely clear that we will not rest
until we have recovered seal there is no
way that people will escape paying their
sell that's due simply by
waiting and waiting and wait
ing anyway so there are a series of
steps ultimately they end up in court
and the one in lavignons I think two or
three days before the court hearing and
um and the developer paid so what we're
going to be looking at in the next
review is
why people find that situation
attractive that's develop
that's the reason they find that
situation attractive is because the cost
of them borrowing money is quite high is
rising the development industry
historically is quite a heavy borrower
um so they are borrowing money at a
higher rate than we charge for overdue
and late still so they're effectively
borrowing from our sealed pot
and doing so at a cheaper rate than
other means of borrowing so that's
something that we're going to have to
have a look at I mean the situation has
changed a lot since the last review in
terms of Base rate interest rates
forecasts
um
inflation CPI so in the next review we
will be looking at if there is anything
that we can do to actually alter that to
make it less attractive for some of the
developers to Welch on their sill
payments
uh thank you madam chairman um and thank
you councilor Arthur you have said
everything that I had hoped you would
say on that because I think we actually
need counselors to understand what's
happening and also the residents know
exactly what is happening and through
this platform we can actually let
residents know and I hope some of the
developers are also listening and
watching because they'll know that we
are after them if they have not paid
thank you very much
thank you counselor Mabry
um I think the questions now have
finished and we can now move to debate
councilors will be allowed to speak once
for three minutes and this will be timed
so if anyone would like to open this up
for debate although we've almost been
debating anyway so
[Music]
um
councilman craw thank you
said it yourself chair thank you very
much we have covered it and the of
course we do this every year cell has
been
I don't think I think they don't think
the word triumph is too much of an
overstatement I think everybody's
supported sill bids throughout the
district districts I speak to my
mid-suffolk colleagues on the same
subject
um I would suggest that it's been a
brilliant project Christine's team do a
marvelous job I've just been forwarding
tonight's papers so I can update my own
Parish Council in what the current state
of preparing a seal bid would be they
can look at every single application as
well as using exitcom we have an
excellent sales system it's a model of
its kind I would propose we move
straight to the vote um but just say we
should record our thanks to Christine
and her team and obviously councilor
asked these magnificent presentation
all right I'm just buttering you up mate
anyway I suppose we moved to the vote I
would ask for a seconder for that well
we've still got a few more people okay
whenever we're ready let's go thank you
thank you oh Council
where are you seconding yes I'll be
pleased to Second it and could I also uh
concur with the last speaker
um when Christine was in Planet I
thought she was brilliant there she had
her hand on the uh well she she she she
had um that all under control and
um when we lost her and you moved to
this department still I didn't think
that she'd be able to phone him anything
that would really keep her as interested
as she is and I have to say you and your
team are excellent on this seal uh even
the people that try and get out of
paying you and we all know who they are
uh say that they they admire what you're
doing and that they are prepared to to
talk to you and and I think that we're
very lucky to have our lead in this team
I'm pleased to say thank you
okay so I think we'll now move on to the
vote
um
oh yes I was going to stand up at the
end and just thank Christine
but everybody else has done that for me
so I will also thank again the pan the
panel members um
Kabir was on at Council
Council McLaren hopefully they'll be on
the panel for the next review which
starts shortly and thank them for all of
their good work thank you
thank you councilor arthi and I'm sure
that's um agreed by the rest of the
councilors
thank you I've now lost the corporate
manager governance and Civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
chair that vote is now showing in blue
for councilors to cast their vote
all right
first of all are you having problems
it won't are you on the right one
oh how strange
can I just take your vote then please
chair that is a unanimous vote 20 vote
25 votes for
thank you
that is carried
we'll now move on to item nine
paper BC 22 20.
Vapor midsoffer District Council
sustainable caval vision and local
cycling and walking infrastructure plan
in the absence of councilor gold I would
like to invite councilor Ward to
introduce paper BC 2220 the
recommendations of a noting only
cups award
thank you madam chairman um
we have already heard references to the
LC whip this evening so it is rather
opportunity this update is before us now
I've got a few things to say which has
been prepared for me actually which is
great
um so just bear with me the sustainable
travel vision is the council's
public-facing document which outlines
our reasons and intentions for
encouraging and enabling our residents
to make more environmentally friendly
and healthy choices for short regular
Journeys wherever practical
The Narrative is not anti-car and it
appreciates and understands that most of
us will still need to rely on the car
for many Journeys rather it is about
asking people to think about and change
behaviors regarding how certain Journeys
they are making could be more
environmentally friendly and better for
their own health and well-being and also
about how the council will work with
Partners to encourage and facilitate
this Behavior change
the LC web is specifically about active
travel cycling and walking
to promote health and well-being it is a
national government recommended tool
developed in accordance with their
technical guidance which leaves out the
district's priorities when it comes to
active travel infrastructure investment
RLC whip has been developed through
public consultation a very successful
consultation that received over 1 800
responses and the schemes included have
been those flagged up by the respondents
letting us know where and why there are
currently currently barriers to cycling
and walking
schemes were prioritize by scoring
against a variety of different factors
based on criteria recommended by the
national government methodology guidance
which has been adjusted slightly to
ensure it reflects our two districts
more rural Landscaping needs and agreed
by a joint cross-party working group
from both districts
that process is detailed and the LC
methodology report
the LC web has been utilized by County
Council highways to inform investment
decisions and also by the planning
directorate to seek opportunities for
funding improvements through developer
contributions
it is also assisting a cell team in
identifying schemes that could be
brought forward for funding within the
Ipswich strategic planning Area traffic
mitigation strategy
it is understood that even with
successful public consultation it may be
that other active travel infrastructure
issues arise or get flagged up over time
so the list of schemes does remain
remain a dynamic element with within the
LC width
lists will be regularly reviewed and
reassessed so there will always be the
opportunity for reasonable tweaks and
additions Beyond those already captured
by the consultation
cabinet endorsement enabled has
supported and added confidence to the
sustainable travel vision and how the
council has developed the LC whip
labeling officers to pursue the delivery
of valuable improvements and we are now
bringing this to the potential of all
members
so this support can continue and World
members have an awareness of this work
stream and where to signpost any queries
regarding sustainable and active travel
this report is for noting only
and Catherine Davis is here this evening
to answer any questions
I would like to thank Catherine and
Sarah cave in the economy team for their
work in producing the LC Whip and our
intern Jessica Rose Rosedale who
supported the work and of course the
planners infrastructure team and Suffolk
County Council highways with whom we now
continue to work closely and I hope I
haven't forgotten anyone in that list
thank you madam chairman
the council Ward councils do you have
any questions Council Mabry
um this is just just clarification
because
here if for our residents are actually
um looking at this on page 147 it says
consultations under item seven and
um about four lines from the end it says
was accessed by
3431 visitors so that visitors to
Suffolk is that visitors to baber or is
that just to the website
well councilor macroth you may
understand
residents at home may not and if I have
had
3431 visitors in Lebanon in the past six
weeks well I was hoping for a few more
thank you very much
you like to answer that Council award
yeah I would
um leaving aside the words that are in
Brackets the sentence is the
consultation website was accessed by
3431 visitors so it is a reference to
the website
thank you any other questions
okay so if there are no further
questions counselor did you want to add
anything
no thank you madam chairman thank
you my case that report for noting only
so we'll now move on to item 10.
item 10 paper BC
2221 localism act 20 20 2011 appointment
of independent persons I would like to
invite the monitoring officer to
introduce this report thank you
thank you chair I'm pleased to introduce
this report which asks the council to
appoint independent persons for the
purposes of code of conduct complaints
I'm really delighted to be able to
propose five names to the council this
evening which will give a good pool of
people and ensure that there aren't any
conflicts of interest when any of those
individuals are dealing with any
particular complaint I'm also really
pleased that our Consortium in terms of
appointing the independent persons has
grown to include West Suffolk as well so
we now have the County Council Ipswich
by Council baber and mid-suffolk
councils and West Suffolk Council using
the same pool of independent persons
chair I'm very happy to answer any
questions and would ask great professor
and seconder for the recommendations
thank you
thank you so can I have a proposer
please councilor Simon Barrett I guess
I'm happy to propose the people around
I think I might have been in that one as
well
but uh um just to say with my experience
it's always good to have a nice balanced
View and I'm sure these people will be
nice and independent and make and make
sure that the function of the council is
continued in a nice
it shouldn't do your way
thank you Council Barrett councilor
Arthur were you looking to sign thank
you
um did anyone want to
um have any questions
oh sorry councilor Mabry um thank you
madam chairman um
I would admit to my gender being female
um and to my in my opinion perhaps the
um monitoring officer will confirm all
five are
female we had no males or any other
gender applying for these positions
um I some people might find this as a
strange question but I don't because I'm
all for openness transparency and
equality for all things
I think thank you chair um monitoring
information equality monitoring
information was collected from all of
the candidates we actually had 20 people
apply but obviously gender is not
something that is taken into
consideration with any recruitment
exercise and so the five candidates that
are put in front of you this evening are
simply the best five following the uh
application process and then an
interview which involved the deputy
management officer and the monitoring
officers from the other partner councils
thank you
any other questions
thank you so
we can now open it to debate would would
anyone like to open the debate
I think we'll go straight to a vote
thank you I will ask the corporate
manager of governments and Civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that is now showing in
blue for councilors to cast their vote
chair that is 24 4 and 1 abstention
thank you that is carried
we'll now move on to item 11.
paper BC 22 22 appointment of monitoring
officer I would like to invite the Keith
executive to introduce this report
thank you chairman and good evening
councilors um as councilors will be
aware this is uh Emily Euler's last
meeting and as a result we do need to
appoint a replacement monitoring officer
to the authority I was hoping to be able
to ask you this evening to appoint the
person named within the report as our
interim monitoring officer unfortunately
however since we interviewed and agreed
to the appointment it's now not possible
for that person to join us on a
part-time basis so I'm asking you to
withdraw this report this evening I will
bring back the same report but with a
different name towards the end of the
month I'm confident that we'll be able
to do so having carried out some
interviews so far this week and further
interviews tomorrow so I am confident
being able to make an appointment what I
will do in the interim as you would
otherwise be without a monitoring
officer I will exercise my emergency
Powers so that it fills the gap between
Monday at through until your next
meeting but I will then ask you to
formally confirm that actually your next
meeting at the end of the month so as I
said ask you we draw the meeting or
sorry report for this evening
thank you
as our chief Executives said this is the
last meeting that our monitoring officer
Emily your will be with us so I just
wanted to say a few words
since becoming chairman I've been
fortunate to being flanked at this desk
by two fantastic strong and
well-informed women
today for me personally which is a
particularly poignant meeting as this is
the last full council meeting with this
advice and support of my right hand
woman Emily Euler
I'm often amazed at the intelligence and
depth of knowledge that Emily has at her
fingertips during our meetings
but as we all know it is not only at
Council meetings that were treated to
Emily's expertise
as a monitoring officer her role has so
many facets and on the several occasions
I have sought her advice I'm always in
awe of her wisdom and professionalism
personally I have used her as a sounding
board and even Agony aunt and she was
always even-handed and always right
I have said in the past how the
difficult full Council meetings during
covert lockdowns helped form bonds for
me anyway
and chats with Emily during that time
became something to look forward to as
well as her lovely welcoming smile and
calm manner
I know I can speak on behalf of all of
us counselors in saying that we will
miss your wise counsel Emily and your
support
I also know that we all wish you all the
best of luck for the future
we baby counselors will certainly miss
you and I definitely will thank you
[Applause]
so
after that
we wish you all the best and we'll move
on to the next
item
yeah item 12.
paper BC 22 23.
urgent action taken by the chief
executive under delegated powers in
accordance with part two of The
Constitution
I'd like to invite the chief executive
to introduce this report which is for
noting
thank you madam chairman I suspect this
report stands for itself and there's
very little I need to say but just to
confirm in order to enable freston
Parish Council to continue to be able to
make decisions as you can see I've made
the decision to appoint several of their
number having had them leave as a result
of missing the six-month rule that
you'll all be familiar with so I felt
non-controversial report to enable local
government interesting to continue
thank you that report was for noting
only
cancer appointments are there any
changes to placings
thank you in that case we'll move on to
motions on notice
item a
to consider the motion on notice receive
from councilor Jameson
and I believe you've all received new
oh that's the next one sorry councilor
Jameson would you like to move your
motion
um thank you madam chair
um yeah
yeah it's the last one
um I'm just going to say um
relating to this motion unfortunately
the shocking state of the UK's housing
market is contributing to the cost of
living crisis rising and also the the um
the effects of climate change gets
becoming more urgent
energy costs are putting a huge burden
on all of us and we're all concerned
about the cost of heat in our homes
this fear is even worse for people who
are not the least well off in our
district
the best way to reduce the energy costs
is to
reduce the need for heating in the first
place as much as possible and to include
renewable energy
to do this a bottle of retrofitting
on scale to tackle this has been
pioneered by Lewis Council the model is
an ambitious plan that could allow local
councils to transform
their local retrofit sectors listing
people out of fuel poverty creating jobs
and slashing carbon emissions
by teaming up with other local councils
in our area we could create a similar
program for insulating and installing
renewable energy on scale
in Social homes across our region
by targeting at the housing directly in
their control we can help kick-start
comprehensive retrofitting across all
housing sectors in the local area
however doing this in isolation is too
expensive for a single Council
by pulling Resources with six other
councils in their area Lewis were able
to create a one billion pound fund by
2030
and enabling them to tackle 40 000 homes
at that level it's possible to get huge
economies of scale
model takes the idea of a localized
economy with Supply chains that keep
economic value and jobs within the area
instead of Outsourcing them and applies
it to the retrofit sector
by then prioritizing training through a
council-led task force it should also be
possible to make sure that the jobs that
will be created stay local and add value
to our economy
by investing in the creation of local
stable supply chain and Workforce
we can also bring down the price of
retrofitting so that all households not
just theirs can then access the market
this motion should have come to us back
in July and subsequently mid-suffolk
have already approved a similar motion
as stated in the papers this motion is
calling on baber to agree to research
this model and to start dialogue with
other local authorities and external
stakeholders
to investigate if a similar project
could be initiated in Suffolk
to improve the pace of our retrofitting
okay
thank you
um councilor Gould is has given her
apologies
councilor Owen thank you
seconded by councilor Owen
we will now move to the debate
councils will be allowed to speak for
three minutes
and this will be limited this will be
timed
counselor on spawn
thank you madam chairman
um yeah firstly I'd like to confirm that
officers from labor Council have
previously worked with the Suffolk Hub
relating to grant-based claims for green
homes Grant
and business energy and Industrial
strategy funding these funding bids have
been successful in Broad terms across
the partnership authorities but baber
has had more limited success because of
resource challenges around delivery
subsequently mid-suffolk and baber
requested that Suffolk housing board
investigate the lose lose method for
decarbonizing social housing stock and
the short descriptive paper was
completed by the Suffolk housing board
program manager on the 8th of August
this year
subject to the agreement of the shb I
will arrange for this paper to be
circulated to all members of the council
in due course in essence however the
lose model not only combines funding
buying power across seven councils as
you've already alluded to but combines
this with closely linked archetype
approaches across 10 similar property
types for installation investment
approaches to be adopted across some
forty thousand homes
the model goes further than the approach
adopted in Suffolk so far as it also
focuses on products which have been
previously analyzed for carbon footprint
analysis with all necessary funding
being provisionized through the HRA
Grant and borrowing needs these being
assessed against costs and then the
results being fed into the revised HRA
models further work is focused on
critical supply chain infrastructure
challenges and discussions with firms in
the green sector to achieve a
substantial local market have shown to
be possible to increase jobs and
reduction in costs these have been
calculated as being as much as 20
percent
taking account of all these factors and
the motion before the council today I
can confirm that offices of this Council
will review carefully the paper which
the shb program manager has prepared
explaining in detail the lose model and
complete any necessary research to
assess if baber council could work with
other partners across Suffolk to deliver
a similar stock investment approach to
that proposed within the rose initiative
with this I have no problem in
supporting this motion thank you madam
chairman
thank you councilor Osborne
would anyone else like to speak
councilor Busby
yes chair um I'm not sure that involving
council members will actually improve
the pace of retrofitting certainly in my
case
would anyone else like to add anything
thank you
councilor Jameson is there anything else
you'd like to add no no I think
thank you in that case uh we'll move on
to the vote I'd like to ask the
corporate manager governance and Civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that is showing in blue
for cancers to vote
councilor Jameson can you vote please
laughs
chair that is 22 4 and 3 against
thank you that is carried
so we'll move on to Item B now
to consider the motion on notice
received from councilor Simon Barrett
I'll ask the proposal and secondary to
speak
and councilor Davis to respond after
which councilor Ward will be
I will then put the motion immediately
to the vote
councilor Simon Barrett we'd like to
move your motion
promotion to the council
this Council has no confidence in the
current Vice chairman to The
Undertaker's role in partially and the
spirit of a code of conduct and
therefore results to remove councilor
Davis as Vice chairman of baby District
Council
uh subsequently to this both the both
breaches or the code have been upheld by
the power so that is quite clear there's
no question do you are breaches are not
appropriate
I'd ask for a second
yes well I have a second of please as
councilor Fraser has sent his college
Council up here thank you
councilman did you want to speak uh yes
Madam chairman I'll speak now
um
this is a sad occasion
um because
at the end of the day a counselor who's
Vice chairman of this Council should not
be
um behaving like this apparently
to call
conservatives bastards
and he's on his Facebook and so it's
obviously supported by him uh is out of
order I look around this room members
I've been here a long time
uh uh you know obviously Council arfi
John Hinton we've been here a long time
if any of you
would call that in my presence I would
be just as cross-abated as I am uh now
so it's totally out of order in fact
it's one of those situations that you
should have known better
um
to imply that the people that voted for
me
are bastards
that would fall down to my colleagues
opposite councilor McLaren Ward Adrian
and Jane Osborne were all elected by
conservatives
and if you condone this and do not vote
against it you you you're doing a
disservice to those people
I I wanted to um
point out that this is not a joke or Tit
for Tat
um but this is a nasty fishes and shows
utter hatred towards conservatives
I'm not talking about
the attacks and the bullying that has
gone on to three members of this Council
which is councilor Barrett councilor
um Michael Fraser and councilor Sean
Dawson they're big enough to to fight
for themselves but I will not stand by
and allow you to refer to the people
that I represent and who vote for me in
fact I'll go as far as to tell you that
you won't be welcome in great cornard at
all
by the elected conservative members
there
so please remember that any of you that
support him staying in his position
really need to look at your
Consciousness because this isn't the
sort of thing you do
we shouldn't be in this situation and I
I would say to you really think about it
because hopefully the public out there
will realize what's happening this has
gone on for a long time the leader of
this Council John Ward when he was
leader of the conserv official
conservatives he was appalled by the
actions that were going on and not being
stopped so to to get to this stage now
and I didn't want to stand up here
councilor Fraser had got strong feelings
on this very strong films and he wanted
to be here but unfortunately he can't I
was asked at the 11th hour so I've got
nothing wrote down but I I feel very
strongly yes you all know I'm a
conservative and always will be and what
have you and I know the disadvantages of
that but I respect members of the
opposition do you have your views I
think you're rotten most of the time but
you still have your views councilman and
I have often had banjo a chamber but
we've never resorted to this and it
shouldn't be like that so I would
respectfully ask you all to remove him
from this possession of representing us
as Vice chairman of this Council thank
you
to say but I did share a social media
post which was on my timeline
I totally reject the suggestion that
this affects my impartiality as baber
Vice chair in any way whatsoever
if by sharing this post
offended anyone which I clearly have
I have already apologized
I realize it was an error of judgment
and I took the post down pretty quickly
and that's been dealt with
during my seven years plus as an
independent labor District councilor
representing gansey's Ward
I have I believe I have demonstrated a
completely unbiased approach to working
with all members
no matter their group
I've always put people before any Party
politics and I have worked closely with
both conservatives and non-conservatives
in a constructive and impartial way
across a wide range of initiatives and
programs that have benefited all our
residents
this was demonstrated when I chaired the
full council meeting in May as Catherine
Grandin was on holiday
totally impartial and unbiased manner
despite some provocation
but that is sometimes the nature of the
cut and thrust of politics I accept this
reality
even if counselor Barrett and Council of
beer were dolding out all manners of
verbal and non-verbal attack on others
seeing it seems a bit frit if not woke
from them when it comes to dealing with
incoming comments
I have represented baber as Vice chair
on a number of occasions recently and
always acted with total respect and
dignity which fully reflected our
districts in a positive light I looked
to continue in this role and will
continue to respect all aspects of the
office
thank you Council Ward would you like to
speak
and thank you and councilman I can speak
for myself and you know very well um the
discussions that we have had in the past
and my views on the Primacy and
importance of a free press but that's
nothing to do with this evening
Madam chairman I have to say I'm rather
disappointed at the snide reference in
the full written version of this notion
in today's agenda to my failure to
respond to the Facebook posts and I
would like to have the opportunity to
clarify this
councilman Mary Melanie Barrett's email
to me drawing the post to my attention
was sent when I was on holiday and she
would have received an out of office
reply from my mail account informing her
of that councilor Simon Barrett also
sent me a text during my holiday
I had no intention of reading or
responding to emails until I returned
and pointed this out to councilor
Melanie Barrett when she sent me the
first draft of this motion but it seems
she has declined to remove the
misleading comment
I feel an apology is warranted but I
guess a political Point must be made no
matter how flimsy the pretext
I do of course deprecate insults like
this they caution the political debate
and implicitly condone the abuse of
politicians that has reached deplorable
levels in recent years
as you all know I more than anyone am
very aware of this due to the vile abuse
I have received and the outrageous lies
told about me from some frankly very
unpleasant people on social media all of
us here should agree that we do not
support abuse in any way and
individually and together
we should be prepared to call out abuse
loudly and publicly even at the risk of
attracting the attention of the abusers
it is good to see that both councilor
Davis and councilor Barrett have
apologized this evening for their
transgressions they are different but
ultimately both have the potential to
tarnish the reputation of the council
I think we should all learn from this
but for now consider the apologies to be
closure and thereby enable us all to
move forward in a more respectful manner
as I said in my leaders announcements
hashtag debate not hate thank you madam
chairman
thank you Council
of water how can you Guillotine
something as important as this when
members have given up their time to come
here I have already give them three
minutes to speak no this is not a matter
for debate I sat at the outset that we
all go straight to the vote
thank you
I mean I'm sorry
I stated that in the
Earth
we are going straight to the boat to
address the chair
allowed
and
um the response was because I was
mentioned in the motion it was because I
was mentioned in the motion I'm going to
ask someone as the monitoring officer to
speak
thanks chair um firstly I just
respectfully remind councilors of
protocol and etiquette in the council
chamber
um secondly we do not have debate on
appointments and the motion you're
considering tonight is effectively the
reverse of an appointment so the same
rules apply the chair has used her
discretion to allow Council award to
speak because he was mentioned in the
motion but it is the chair's discretion
to allow any other counselors to speak
but I will repeat that in matters of
appointment or indeed removal we do not
allow debate because quite often it
becomes very personal and can become
quite nasty so that's the
Reacher
before okay so we will now move to the
vote
thank you
if counselors can cast their vote thank
you
foreign
chair that is seven for the motion
sixteen against and two abstentions
that motion is lost
we'll now move to item C now there is
another information on notice received
from councilor Lindsay
councilor Lindsay would you like to move
your motion
I believe you've you've submitted some
amended papers
counselor yes thank you chair
um
I uh
the reason I've that well can I I'd like
to amend it sorry about this I'd like to
amend it a little bit more because after
discussions with senior officers
um so the proposal
amended one would add two more points
seven and eight to the end
um let me just get the
SE so 9.7
um actually this comes from I'm grateful
to council McCraw who's on the Suffolk
flood risk management subcommunity so
0.7 is to ask the Suffolk flood risk
management subcommittee to examine the
cumulative impact of development on
watercourses
um
0.8
this is a little bit more complicated
but
um
0.8 I'll read it out is to ask overview
and scrutiny committee to examine
whether planning officers should include
in all reports relating to major
development a specific section on the
impact
on watercourses
including the potential for the
development to affect sewage outflow
into watercourses or to flag this
information to flag if this information
is not fully available
um
they're just just to explain now for me
the whole motions I'm not sure
the Amendments make any sense unless I
explain the whole thing
um
so let me get my notes up
there we go
so what this motion is about is
overflows storm overflows which belong
to
Anglia water
there are 35 of them in in our area
along the store and and these
tributaries
um what are they storm overflows they're
installed by what were then waterboards
in the 1950s as a kind of pressure
release valve for the sewage Network
the idea was that when there was a storm
or exceptionally heavy rain
the storm overflows would ensure that
sewage
spills into the rivers instead of
backing up through the drains and going
flooding the streets or people's homes
um I I don't I'm I'm
don't remember those days but apparently
back before then you could get the
rather nasty experience of sewage coming
back up the drain at you in a time of
the storm so it puts this when when
there is a storm now because rain water
uh in in the sewage system we have in
most of East Anglia rainwater goes into
the sewage is mixed in and so the
pressure builds up and they have to
release it into rivers uh so that's
that's what uh storm outflows are
um unfortunately I mean the idea at the
time was that people would be unlikely
to be swimming in the rivers when there
was a storm so it didn't
a little bits of poo floating past but
um since then many more homes and
businesses have been built with many
more people producing sewage
and then a few years back angling water
installed monitors on this on these
score mode flows to see how often they
were spilling out sewage into the rivers
and actually it's no longer an
exceptional occasion it's no longer just
when there are storms or heavy rain
in 2021 these overflows chucked out raw
sewage into our Rivers for 1
861 hours
the the problem has become so large it's
been noticed by the chief medical
officer of the country Chris Whitty who
in July this year issued a statement is
actually published as an op-ed in a day
in the Sunday Telegraph raw sewage from
Storm Out storm overflows this is what
he I'm quoting from this is notice we're
all sewage from Storm overflows and
continuous discharge of waste
containing viable organisms from sewage
treatment works is an anchor is an
increasing problem
so he's acknowledged there's a problem
there from Storm overflows
um he says it is clear that water
companies are not doing enough
Public Health dangers are in addition to
the ecological and environmental impact
which forms the basis for much
regulation
so the core of this motion
um what what am I doing with this motion
to address to address how can we as a
council address this problem of store
motor flows happening almost all the
time instead of exceptional occasions
um well we got we're we're planning
authority of course and the nppf makes
clear that planning authorities are
expected to prevent developments
polluting waterways
um but up to now when we have planning
applications for major developments
we've not asked angling water to report
on whether it will lead to an increase
in emergency discharge
they tend to comment on whether this
capacity in the network and not if
there's a problem if if it will increase
emergency discharge from these storm
overflows
um
so as a planning Authority determining
both the overall amount of development
in our district
uh and allocations in each area of
Housing and individual applications for
for major developments it is right that
we take the impact of extra housing
um
but on the on the Storm overflows and
the subsequent uh pollution and sewage
that enters our Rivers
so just to
um go back to
to I think perhaps item eight may have
confused a few people
so the original item eight I had asked
directly planning officers from now
onwards to include in all reports on
major developments that they put before
the planning committee
um
a specific item on the potential impact
from this development on
us
um on the Storm overflows and and the
water quality of our Rivers
um but having discussions with with
officers particularly from the planning
side
um
uh I I decided to refer this to suggest
instead that we refer to overview and
scrutiny that particular request
simply to give officers chance to get a
legal to consult but get a legal opinion
on whether it it's practical to do
hope that helps
thank you could I have a secondary
Deb thank you councilor Jameson
um so now we can put this open to debate
customer crawl
thank you chair
um
I wasn't expecting to talking about this
but um I'm and have been for some years
this council's representative on the
aforementioned
almost unwieldy title ever Suffolk flood
risk management scrutiny subcommittee
has represents represent I would talk
across the room but it doesn't seem a
lot of the point apparently a number of
members are not interested
flooding
I think I've become quite passionate
about water on this thing because we
aren't just looking at flood management
we're actually looking at water quality
across the board to such an effect that
in July of this year no May of this year
the 17th of May we had such a meeting as
is
posted towards uh by this motion and it
was on the quality of suffolks rivers
and Coastal Waters I have to say that
both anglian water and the environment
agency working as it were hand in glove
one providing the information for the
other something I pointed out at the
time could be seen the conflict of
interests we were able to examine as
much as it was possible but I have to be
confessed that we did not receive what I
would call fully detailed data
um missing out the whole of the store
Basin as far as I could tell oh and all
the coastline
which I thought was quite a missing
thing they did provide some figures
later on but frankly
water quality and Suffolk Rivers broadly
we ain't got any good ones what we've
got is a lot of mediocre ones and we
have one or two bad ones apparently
nowhere in England has good water
quality in its river system which is
which is allowing in itself so I fully
support this I'm particularly going to
support the idea that we extended to
include the impact cumulative impact as
I said stated in the motion
because one of the things that if we
look at in water quality is where's it
coming from it's not there's so many
different types of water we have the
concept of gray water
um as well as flood water as well as
sewage discharge as well as agricultural
discharge as well as surface water
drainage we're all familiar with Suns
water is complicated
and the fact that the matter is suffered
gets less of it than anywhere else and
is going to need more of it is estimated
in the course of the next 30 Years this
County will on the whole of East England
actually will require 40 percent more
water just to stay standing still so I'm
going to support this and I'd also like
to particularly support that a request
be made to the Suffolk flood management
scrutiny subcommittee on this particular
point about development impact I believe
the other
District councilors who also sit on that
committee would welcome it because we're
all on local planning authorities and
sometimes we don't easily join up the
local planning Authority and the local
flood Authority and frankly we should
because it's actually becoming a
critical matter for us to deal with so
that's all I just hope you'll vote for
it
although it might need tidying up
thank you councilman craw would anyone
else like to council Ward all right yeah
this this isn't really um part of the
debate it's actually some clarification
um councilor Lindsay you you've made a
reference to
um paragraph eight which is in one of
the earlier drafts of this now what we
have in front of us has just got six
um so it is that one that we're
voting on this evening the the final
amendment was only six separate
paragraphs or not because that's what I
have in the table of papers
so my amendment to what you've got
before you is adding seven and eight and
I think the amendment's being accepted
so that there was just for clarification
in the earlier version there was a seven
and eight then it went down to six you
know saying it's back up to 70. it is
yeah
um so I need to have visibility of that
before I um because I don't can't see
that in front of me I can't see the
words
I could I mean
I can um
I'm very happy with the one to six
because the original
um one to set one to eight
um had one or two issues which have been
um tidied up and clarified and the one
to six that I have here is excellent I'm
happy to vote for that but uh I'd like
to see if I've got another revision I'd
like to see that could
work
because you've got a written bit haven't
you send it via email to
members I'm going to also ask the
monitoring officer to explain to us the
the
um legal background on on what we can
and can't do in this regard yes
you just want to put screen don't you
yeah thank you chair um the motion on
notice can be amended up until any point
that it's proposed and seconded so
councilor Lindsay can make amendments
verbally on the night but obviously the
council does need to know exactly what
those amendments are I believe we have
the wording and that's being circulated
to members
um
we might be able to put it on screen yes
I won't because that would be beyond my
technical capabilities
um but once you have that word and then
you can make a decision as to whether
you uh want to vote on those additional
bits or not yes but I think I think the
key point is that the council needs to
be very clear on what you're voting on
before you take that vote
I think it might happen so
um what counts as like a five minute to
German so to allow us to get it up on
the screen
no
oh you've emailed it to everyone
and these add on to the other things yes
yes so you should all now have the email
counselors
so you should be able to see what your
own calendar
foreign
it's only a technical Point Madam chair
it's just the fact that um we're asking
Suffolk Club management scrutiny
subcommittee
to examine the cumulative impact of
development on watercourses they would
be capable of interpreting that And
discussing it with Nigel lens sorry
councilor Lindsay
um
but councilor Lindsay's points can be
fed in to as another body they'd be
quite happy to listen I'm sure
thank you
did anyone else wish to
Hinton
yes very briefly I'd like to support
this as well I'm glad it's been the
wording's been clarified now we've all
got the wording through which makes it a
lot a lot simpler I would just add that
uh
the store Wild Water swimmers
don't swim in the store anymore because
it's too polluted so they don't like to
swim around with little bits of
as Council Lindsey graphically put
um but I would also just urge a slight
note of caution when it I for many years
I sat with on the
Suffolk flood resilient forum
which was disbanded soon after Suns came
in because it was decided that the Suns
would actually uh sort out that that
part of things and during the course of
that exercise we had a training session
where we looked at flooding in the
middle of Ipswich
where they decided that
tide had come in and flooded the middle
of Ipswich
until I pointed out to them that if they
looked at Ipswich docks there is a
concrete wall all the way along its fish
docks about 20 feet back from the edge
of the key
the ramps going up and over it
so that lorries and vehicles and
forklifts Etc can go up and over to
unload the facilitate unloading the
ships and moving it into warehouses and
if the water got behind that how hell
were they going to get it out
because there was no facility for
letting the water out and they said oh
boy we'll knock a hole in it with a
bulldozer and I said next time the tide
comes in he goes straight back in again
so they're not exactly the most logical
Bunch some of these uh these flood
planners so we've got to make it put it
in Crystal Clear wording of one syllable
to make sure that they come up with
something that's correct
thank you councilor Parker
yeah thanks Jeff
um I just if you don't mind me saying I
I think the sentiment of this is
absolutely spot on
but to my mind this is just it's just a
little bit woolly we've got four points
here that begin with the with the word
ask
um so we can with all good intentions
yes we can ask but there doesn't seem to
be anything concrete here that suggests
what might happen if the answer to that
ask
for 50 of the motion is no
um so it to my mind it's just it's just
I I like the sentiment but I'm half
wondering if there isn't even an
argument
for maybe the proposer to withdraw this
motion and bring it back maybe to the
next Council once it's been tidied up a
bit
um that's that's just a common chat
thank you
councilor arthi
I Have A Little Bit of Sympathy with
that as well
um I have to say that with what's
happened this evening
um I did think to myself all this was
supposed to be a motion on notice and
the whole point of notice is to tell us
what you're going to be proposing in
good time give us
um but in actual fact what we've ended
up with is something that we're
scrapping around trying to understand on
the night because the notice we had that
we all read
um has changed quite a lot
and change it as much as you like but
all we've really ended up is noticed
that you were going to propose a motion
and we find out what it is on the night
so I tend to have a Little Bit of
Sympathy with what councilor Parker said
um having said that though I think I've
actually now
um got to the bottom of all of your
amendments and seven and eight so I
think I could probably roll with it but
I didn't have a sympathy with the phone
would you prefer to withdraw it for now
and come back next time can could he do
that in two weeks time
yes it could if if it's if possibility
agreed to that yeah hopefully in two
weeks time of course so if councilor
Lindsay agreed to that second I'm sorry
I
um perhaps it helps if I I mean what I
appreciate the difficulty that that some
members have
um but I think if I can just explain the
point of of the point of point the new
0.7
um councilman craw I think it's made
quite clear that
we've got a body that looks at this
these issues that scrutinizes them so it
makes sense
um to refer that the issue to them
particularly in relation to development
because that's the bit they haven't
looked at
point eight
where we're we're simply
um
rather than directly saying to officers
you've got to put something in your
reports about this
we're saying that
you know because of advice I've had from
officers they're a bit uncomfortable
with it the planning offices are a bit
uncomfortable with it
concern about what the committee how
committees will take this and so on
um so you know the suggestion was refer
it to overview and scrutiny
to give give officers time to just get a
legal
opinion on
because we're sort of meddling with
planning things so which is all legally
bound about so so the idea is to to get
a legal opinion on it and then be in
scrutiny to look at that particular I
but I think the rest of it
isn't isn't that controversial
um on the point of
it's it's vague and asking
I think
um it's it's quite carefully worded
[Music]
um
I mean ask the chair of the scrutiny
committee well he's not the chair's not
going to say no are they
um but we have to we as a council have
some Authority
well maybe maybe the chair is but
there's nothing however long I go away
for and think about it I can't force
councilor Hinton
so yes okay we'll scrutinize it I can't
force angling water to change their
policy but we as a council have some
influence if we vote for this we can
influence them
using the public as a as a lever and
embarrass them a bit perhaps if they
don't provide the information that's
that's the idea behind this
councilor Busby
well I think we all agree with the
sentiment of it I think the whole thing
should go to Wellness
thank you
councilor plum
thank you chair
um as well have been one person in this
room that receives this water from the
stair long before the rest of him get it
you'll have my sympathy
um
it's me Robert
um I'm going to give you the planning
Chairman's view of this and I think
before we vote I'd have to have it tidy
now
I think I'm sorry but at this stage we
haven't had time to reflect on it I love
the sentiment but um at this moment in
time if this has to go forward and we
have to act as a planning meeting I'm a
little bit concerned that we haven't
really got it tied down legally of
otherwise thank you
thank you
I'd rather I'm monitoring officer is
just going to say a few words
um thank you chair I'm sensing there
isn't a consensus in the room so I'd
just like to give you an option
um of an alternative Motion in the
Constitution that you might want to put
to good use
um so uh rule 15 1 D allows the council
to move to refer a matter to the
appropriate body or an individual and So
to avoid counselors having to withdraw
the motion this evening and also to
avoid other councilors having to vote on
something they're perhaps not entirely
clear about the council could resolve
under motions without notice to refer
this matter to a body such as the
overview and scrutiny committee or back
to officers to do further work before
coming back to council with a more
complete and rounded proposal
thank you
um councilor Lindsay how do you
what is your comment on that
uh so what's the procedure do we do we
have a vote on this and if it fails we
can refer to all your viewing screen or
do we have to have it does it work like
an amendment
how's it what do you need to get to
refer to overview in scrutiny
if if the council votes tonight and it
fails then it's failed and you can't
return to this topic for six months
um but somebody could put from the floor
to use emotion without notice which is
Rule 15 1D and make that that motion
um immediately and if it's second it
would go straight to the vote and the
matter would be referred
can I just ask chair and monitoring
officer referred to whom
um officers overviewed scrutiny or
Suffolk flood management scrutiny
subcommittee
um I do point this out and I'm not gonna
we have representation as does
mid-suffolk on a body which has this
specific rim of this subject
it seems to me that that would be an
appropriate place to refer it to without
involving necessarily I mean we've been
on that committee for some years or some
of us have anyway so there's some
experience of what's involved in
examining Water Management problems so
it just seems the appropriate body is
all
Council well frankly I have pointed out
that I did find myself dissatisfied with
this examination that took place in May
and I've expressed that at the time
Chris well
nothing I I think Robert's idea is a
good idea and I understand people's
sentiments about getting it tidied up
I think rather than go for it tonight as
to put it and lose it completely for six
months a fortnight probably is the best
way forward because we all agree with it
but we'd like to see it a bit clearer
so I'm being advised that we need that
the best option is to put it to officers
to revise the wording
and then it will come back to us in two
weeks time at the next council meeting
at which time we will then vote on the
motion but we've revised flirting
there so can I have a proposer and a
seconder for that action please
councilor Hinton councilor Creswell
councilor Hinton could I just say
something wrong and that is that uh I
support the principle behind this we've
got to sort it out properly bringing it
back in two weeks time
I think is the most advantageous
proposal it also would give us time to
have a look at it and see whether there
is something that if the planning
officers are not very happy with it
perhaps we can look at the possibility
of a supplementary planning document to
go with the joint local plan that would
cover this area because there are spds
being produced all the time at the
moment
thank you councilor Hinton Council
acrosswell you are seconding did you
want to say anything
no I think I said uh a minute ago I
believe it was best to come to two weeks
so I think we're now going to go
straight to the vote
on this occasion I actually do I think
if we've got a body
sole purpose or not sole purpose but one
of their key purposes actually is to
sort out this kind of stuff then we
should be directing
our efforts to encourage them to come up
with Solutions and uh not necessarily
the council it's
it's like having experts then trying to
Cobble something together yourself
this needs to go to their next meeting
well if if we put it to the vote it will
then come back to us in two weeks time
at which time we can properly debate it
um with revised wording that we will
have all had time to look at it look at
Council award yeah
don't wish to be a patent but it's
actually three weeks time
for information only chair
I mean at the Suffolk flight management
scrutiny subcommittee might not be
meeting for some time it's generally
twice a year but I do think it would be
helpful for officers to be able to deal
with Matt Hollis and the local flood
authority to try and set up the time
it's going to take to produce a unified
report covering all of the various water
impacts that arise from development as
well as the existing problems that we
know about
thank you
so we're now going to go to the vote on
this
on on whether we are going to
cherish and through you there should be
an additional vote showing can you see
that so um that is now set off and
should be showing in blue for you to
cast your vote on that amended version
a question sorry
um can we confirm what the appropriate
body is that officers or
okay fine
you have
councilman McLaren can you can you see
the boat too you can't can I take your
boat
um manually
so that the it's too yeah so the motion
the amendment is to agree emotion
without notice
in accordance with rule 15
um 1D
thank you
chair that is 18 votes for the amendment
all right
so yeah so that is carried
um right we're drawing to an end
with this meeting
thank you all
for an interesting meeting
and thank you again to Emily for all her
time advice
and professionalism
and all the best in the future to Emily
and just to let you know that the date
of the next meeting is
Tuesday the 25th of October at 5 30. and
I'd just like to draw your attention
that we'll be starting uh we'd like to
meet earlier
um because there's going to be a
photographer here to take photographs of
us
um
for um so please come to the chamber at
five for the next meeting on Tuesday the
25th
so we're going to have a group well a
council full Council photo
thank you